[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue à tous dans ce
nouveau numéro du 7-8 l'hebdo une
émission pour revenir sur l'actualité
départementale de la semaine voici les
titres de ce vendredi 8 septembre le
conseil départemental à l'heure de la
rentrée pierre bédier a dévoilé ce
vendredi une série de mesures concernant
les collèges du département avec
notamment l'accélération du plan
numérique eric allouche est notre invité
pour cette émission directeur exécutif
du réseau era immobilier nous évoquerons
avec lui la polémique autour des apl et
des loyers ou encore les pistes
envisagées pour répondre à la crise du
logement en région parisienne enfin dans
le reste de l'actualité retour sur la
rentrée scolaire dans les yvelines et le
premier salon du tourisme d'affaires
organisé jeudi à saint quentin en
yvelines
c'était un symbole du monde de la
culture de la mode à la france est
militant engagé dans la lutte contre le
sida et la cause lgbt
pierre bergé est décédé ce vendredi
matin à l'âge de 86 ans l'ex compagnon
d'yves saint laurent était connue des
yvelinois il était le président du
conseil d'administration de la maison
emile-zola située à médan sa disparition
est évidemment un choc pour de nombreux
acteurs locaux écouter deux réactions
recueillies au téléphone ce vendredi
pierre bergé était un acteur qui étaient
vraiment engagés dans la solidarité dans
les luttes contre les discriminations et
effectivement il va enfin des tableaux
choc puisque ben nous on connaissait
bien il a soutenu à chaque prévention
pendant des années on a même eu notre
première unité mobile de dépistage du
dépistage du sida qui était donc financé
par sa fondation
c'était un mécène un ami des artistes
voilà ça a été un compagnon de route
aussi de la gauche française il faut
reconnaître cela est lui resté fidèle
mais plus encore c'est un symbole je
crois pour tous les progressistes à vis
d'une société plus tolérante et plus
solidaire dans le reste de l'actualité
locale conseil départemental des
yvelines a fait sa rentrée ce vendredi
le président du
du département pierre bédier a présenté
à la presse les différentes mesures
concernant les collèges et vinoir entre
investissements pour rénover les
établissements et le déploiement du plan
numérique
les détails avec ce reportage de nicolas
landry et axel duroux est belle donc ses
tablettes au bout des 2 de les avoir
aussi pour la contrer c'est la nouveauté
de la rentrée pour ces élèves en
situation de handicap du collège henri
iv de meulan en yvelines des tablettes
numériques
un nouvel outil prévu par le plan
numérique du département
au total 23 tablettes ont été livrés à
cet établissement
vous êtes content de retrouver ça dans
l'établissement lorsqu'on vous parle
d'henri iv que
à voir quelques extraits de téléfilm sur
henri iv qui passe par la tablette
numérique
c'est vrai que ça rend le court plus
vivant ça permet de mieux capter
l'attention des élèves en plus du
numérique le département s'engage dans
des travaux de rénovation et dans la
sécurité des collèges pour 2017 le
budget éducation s'élève à près de 140
millions d'euros en hausse de 10% par
rapport à 2016 des réflexions sont
engagées sur la politique tarifaire de
la restauration et sur des internats
d'excellence comme celui de marly le roi
objectif de ce type d'établissements
scolaires réduire la fracture
territoriale et donc permettre à des
enfants de jeunes adolescents de quitter
des quartiers défavorisés le temps de
leurs études en semaine pour être plus
au calme et plus dans leur recherche
d'excellence
autre expérimentation dans tout ce
collège de six communes du département
notamment à trappes des chargés de
mission pour faire de la prévention
auprès d'élèves en difficulté le
département toujours qui vient d'envoyer
avec les agglomérations de saint quentin
en yvelines et versailles grand parc une
lettre au premier ministre edouard
philippe
à propos de la future ligne 18 du grand
paris express les collectivités locales
de même que le calendrier du projet soit
accéléré pour desservir notamment
l'agglomération saint-quentinoise dès
2024 en vue des jeux olympiques
la rédaction de tv 78 vous proposera un
reportage complet sur le sujet dès la
semaine prochaine
la polémique a débuté au coeur de l'été
et s'est poursuivie en cette semaine de
la rentrée scolaire l'annnonce de la
baisse prochaine des appels de 1,5 euro
continue de faire réagir notamment les
associations de droit au logement et la
déclaration du président de la
république mardi suggérant aux
propriétaires de baisser aussi le
montant des loyers n'a pas est un la
faire écouter
c'est très embêtant le très triste de
dire ça de croire que ça va faire
baisser les loyers déjà la demande qui
vont faire aux propriétaires dont on
verra mais c'est un désengagement de
l'état de toute façon c'est de dire
c'est aux autres de payer les locataires
de leur côté à on sait très bien qu'ils
vont pas le faire alors les loyers
vont-ils vraiment baissé de 5 euros en
même temps que les apl nous allons poser
la question directement à notre invité
du jour eric allouche bonsoir bonsoir
vous êtes le directeur exécutif du
réseau era immobilier plusieurs de vos
agents sein sont installés sur le bassin
de saint quentin en yvelines
pensez vous alors en tant que
spécialiste du monde ibo immobilier que
que les propriétaires vont baisser comme
le suggère le président de la république
leur loyer de 5 euros dès le 1er octobre
prochain est ce que c'est une affaire
sérieuse celle ci alors je crois que
c'est un cetain sautes d'humeur nos
présidents ont effectivement puisque
c'est très caricatural dire aux
propriétaires baissé de 5 euros tout
simplement parce qu'à une baisse des apl
bon ça relève de l'anecdote
mais c'est pas très sérieux je pense
qu'il faut prendre un peu plus de
hauteur essayez de comprendre les
raisons pour lesquelles les loyers sont
perçus comme étant un peu élevés voire
même le prix des biens ou d'immobilier
qui est en train de monter je pense
qu'il faut il faut bien comprendre la
situation aujourd'hui globale telle
qu'elle existe sur l'ailé sur les loyers
vous avez des loyers qui sont un montant
à un prix beauvue jugé souvent élevés en
tout cas en région ile de france dans
certaines zones pas toutes les villes de
france mais dans beaucoup de zones
d'ile-de-france qui sont élevés alors
pourquoi pourquoi s'est élevé c'est
toujours la même chose si vous voulez si
vous avez un faible volume de biens
disponibles à l'offre de location
forcément derrière les havrais vous
entendre on dit voilà vous avez beaucoup
moins une concurrence qui s'opère donc
tout ça c'est un effet mécanique
je pense qu'il faut prendre les choses
dans la bonne dans la bonne direction ce
que nous avons besoin
rhuys et de plus de logements à louer si
vous avez plus de logements à louer
mécaniquement vous aurez une baisse des
loyers puisque si un propriétaire ne
loupa sont bien forcément parce qu'on a
beaucoup sur le marché il sera obligé de
baisser ses loyers donc je pense qu'il
faut prendre les choses dans le bon sens
et plutôt que de faire peur aux
propriétaires ou de les stigmatiser
je pense qu'il faut plutôt les inciter
nous croyons beaucoup plus à
l'incitation qu'à la coercition pour
revenir sur sur cette affaire on va dire
des appels l'argument prix par emmanuel
macron et le gouvernement c'est de dire
que les propriétaires savent en gros que
beaucoup de français touchent des appels
et que du coup ça peut nourrir à la
hausse les foyers est ce que les loyers
est-ce que c'est comme argument c'est
recevable selon vo ou alors c'est
complètement fantaisistes mais encore
une fois c'est anecdotique parce que ça
voudrait dire que les propriétaires sont
responsables de tout et encore une fois
c'est stigmatise des propriétaires
contre lille plutôt les appels qui sont
responsables alors peut-être que si on
supprimait aujourd'hui les appels 18
milliards d'euros je crois pour par an
pour pour l'état français
peut-être que les loyers baisserait vous
en pensez quoi est ce que c'est alors je
pense qu'il faudra casser karim et les
apl parce qu'on a besoin encore
aujourd'hui notamment certaines
catégories socioprofessionnelles je
pense surtout aux étudiants qui ont
besoin de se loger
donc je pense pas qu'il faille supprimer
des appels nous sommes pas dans une
société où il n'ya pas de social il faut
garder notre volet social ceci dit il
est clair que l'état ne peut pas tout un
moment donné on voit l'augmentation des
logements sociaux voit l'augmentation du
volume avec les obligations des communes
à l'heure où effectivement les communes
ont moins d'argent puisque des dotations
de l'état baisse bes si mécaniquement on
dit que l'état va compenser il va y
avoir quand même une baisse parce qu'il
ya moins d'argent l'état moins d'argent
l'état ne peut pas tout un moment donné
il faut bien comprendre les raisons pour
lesquelles les loyers sont au prix
qu'ils sont aujourd'hui c'est parce
qu'on n'a pas assez de volume si vous
avez du volume vous aurez matt
mécaniquement une baisse
une baisse des loyers donc la solution
c'est construire toujours plus
construire en gros pas propre on va
forcément construire il faut donner
envie aux investisseurs d'investir vous
savez on a besoin de croissance en
france on nous en parle on en parle tout
le temps la croissance est insuffisante
l'immobilier c'est de la croissance
l'immobilier n'est pas un domaine où il
n'y a que des rentiers immobilier
la construction mais l'immobilier c'est
aussi de la rénovation le parc de
rénovation actuellement est en baisse on
s'aperçoit qu'en france il n'y a pas
assez de rénovation il ya beaucoup de
logements qui sont loués qui sont
vétustes ou simplement parce qu'on rogne
sur les rentabilités donc il faut
effectivement privilégié ce domaine du
logement alors tout à l'heure j'ai
évoqué la ligne 18 du grand paris
express on sait que le futur grand paris
qui va arriver dans les prochaines
années va permettre la construction
c'est aussi l'un des objectifs du grand
paris de nombreux logements est ce que
ça peut être l'une des solutions ce
grand paris est ce que vous en attendez
une bonne de bonnes nouvelles notamment
pour pour les loyers pour le et pour le
marché de l'immobilier
alors je pense que c'est une solution
s'il ya du volume si l espace
supplémentaire pour construire c'est une
solution mais ça ne suffit pas pour moi
il faut encore une fois donner envie aux
investisseurs d'investir et pour ça il
faut arrêter de les stigmatiser
et il faut leur donner des raisons
d'investir c'est à dire qu'il faut que
la rentabilité du loyer soit suffisant
si vous avez une rentabilité qui est pas
suffisante qu'est ce qui se passe ce qui
veut dire des gens n'investissent plus
dans les mobiles investir dans
l'immobilier aujourd'hui sa plus
vraiment d'intérêt ça plus beaucoup
d'attrait en france alors ça dépend des
endroits mais la rentabilité très
souvent et rognés et qu'est ce qui se
passe voyez dans les zones tendues comme
à paris vous avez vous avez beaucoup de
propriétaires qui se tourne
le rnb nbi ils sont pas embêtés ils ont
des rentabilités qui sont bien
supérieures et on arrive à des problèmes
où il ya des gens qui sortent du parc
locatif traditionnel
vous voyez donc tout ça c'est très
pervers il faut vraiment donner envie
aux lieux aux propriétaires d'investir
dans l'immobilier traditionnel pour ça
il faut les aider il faut leur donner et
conserver des mesures comme le pin elle
par exemple on voir les choses comme
voilà voire peut-être des mesures
supplémentaires pour qu'ils aient une
rentabilité suffisants aujourd'hui
introduit aussi de fiscalité par exemple
sur le sur le parc privé
oui il ya trop de fiscalité il est clair
près c'est pareil concernant les plus
values
si on réduisait à la dalle la durée de
détention des plus values pour pouvoir
sortir justement des plus values qui
aujourd'hui de 22 ans
dire qu'au bout de 22 ans en fait vous
n'êtes plus imposée sur les plus values
d'accord voilà donc si on réduisait ce
délai à 15 ans se serait ce serait une
bonne chose ça améliorer la fluidité du
parc immobilier y aurait plus de biens à
la vente
parce qu'évidemment les gens ils
prendraient leur leur argent mais ça
ferait plus de volume donc forcément ça
ferait baisser mécaniquement aussi les
prix 2
vous aimeriez un peu votre finalement si
je puis dire votre réforme du code du
travail version macron à vous on est un
peu dans le schéma dans ce que vous
décrivez dans le schéma on a
l'impression très français où il ya
beaucoup de beaucoup de normes beaucoup
de contraintes qui pèsent sur les
investisseurs la réforme du code du
travail de la semaine passée sert à ça à
alléger l'énorme est-ce que aussi vous
attendez vous du plan qui vous est
présenté bientôt qu'on vous facilite la
vie entre guillemets je ne sais pas si
le parallèle est judicieux en faire
vraiment une simili cuir avec ses 2 non
mais c'est pas grave mais je pense je
pense quand même qu'il faut regarder les
données objectives les vraies causes
qu'est ce qui se passe aujourd'hui dans
le logement et traiter les causes mais
pas faire des choses anecdotiques du
genre va écouter ses les propriétaires
ils ont qu'à baisser leur loyer de 5
euros
voyez ça me semble ça ne semble pas très
cohérent et surtout ça ne résout rien je
pense qu'il faut vraiment résoudre les
choses pour résoudre les choses il faut
prendre en compte les données
j'ai là les échos ici les échos de
journal des arbres qui est un très bon
journal qui dit qui donne des éléments
objectifs et qui dit qu'il y a moins de
l'ocades de propriétaires qui louent ya
une baisse de nombre de locataires
il ya une baisse également des
rénovations donc c'est extrêmement
embêtant inquiétant voyez ça veut dire
que les propriétaires bon ont tendance à
moins vouloir rénover chose qui est
effectivement un problème pour les
locataires eux mêmes et on a également
beaucoup de propriétaires qui re de
beaucoup de propriétaires bailleurs donc
des biens disponibles à la location qui
sont revendus à des gens qui ne
remettent plus en location et on a une
baisse du volume des biens à louer ce
qui veut dire qu'aujourd'hui le tel est
l'état du marché immobilier en france
le tableau est plutôt clairement sombre
selon selon ce que vous dites ou alors
vous êtes optimiste
vous savez moi je suis ni son ni
optimise je suis positif naturellement
par contre je regarde les données on a
des loyers qui sont ce là où ils sont
ils sont là où ils sont pour des raisons
précises
essayons de corriger les choses pour que
le volume augmente et que mes tailles
mécaniquement mécaniquement les prix
baissent voyez c'est aussi simple que ça
ton pour ça faut donner envie aux
investisseurs d'investir
il faut améliorer la fluidité du parc
locatif il faut arrêter de stigmatiser
des propriétaires voilà il faut
également permettre aux primo accédants
n'en a pas parlé
j'espère et le jeune le taux a cédé 0,6
en ce moment avec la rentrée
diversiterre on connaît les difficultés
se loger quand on est étudiant
bien sûr mais c'est difficile
effectivement le logement si vous savez
c'est le premier poste de
premier poste de dépenses des français
ça aurait mérité quand même un ministère
on n'a même pas un ministère voyez
bonjour c'est un petit peu dommage bref
je ferme la parenthèse à ce sujet donc
effectivement on est pour des mesures
qui aident les primo accédants
merci eric allouche d'être venu sur le
plateau de tv 78 merci pour vos réponses
je rappelle que vous êtes le directeur
exécutif du réseau era immobilier
merci attention si vous empruntez la
ligne c du rer ce week-end d'importants
travaux sont prévus en direction de
versailles et saint quentin en yvelines
aucun train d'ailleurs ne circulera
entre l'agglomération et le musée
d'orsay à paris
des bus de substitution sont prévues
tout de même pour effectuer vos trajets
plus de précisions sur transilien.com on
passe maintenant à l'actualité de la
semaine
l'actualité à cette semaine marque est
forcément par la rentrée scolaire et la
rentrée des classes dans les yvelines
plus de trois cent cinq mille élèves ont
repris le chemin de l'école lundi une
rentrée avec son lot de nouveautés
rythmes scolaires cpa 12 dans les zones
prioritaires notamment près de 1200
élèves sont d'ailleurs concerné par ce
dédoublement des classes dans les
yvelines
écoutez sur ce sujet le directeur
académique de l'éducation nationale dans
les yvelines où le recevions lundi soir
en plateau plus de 9
cp dans le département sur 10 seront
dédoublés les autres seront co animé
avec deux enseignants paris donnera deux
enseignants par classe mais c'est une
mesure qui est posée systématiquement
dans tous les cp des raids plus avec
encore une fois un accompagnement et une
formation et surtout une confiance au
terrain il faut vraiment j'étais ce
matin avec des professeurs et je leur ai
dit combien avec monsieur le recteur
nous comptions sur eux combien nous leur
faisions confiance et combien cette
question de l'audace d'oser était
extrêmement importante et ils ont ils
choisi d'expérimenter ce n'est pas une
mais des rentrées que le propose l'école
de la deuxième chance en yvelines toute
l'année notamment sur son site
trappistes 100 plats sont par exemple
disponibles au mois de septembre ce
moment l'établissement offre aux 18 25
ans sans formation
la possibilité de bénéficier d'un
accompagnement individualisé et
d'envisager leur avenir professionnel
plus sereinement
un reportage de miquel et demi d'euros
et grégory canal et quand je suis arrivé
ici j'étais vraiment très timide et
grâce à ça ça le connaît déjà une chose
que je puisse ouverte
ils sont beaucoup chaque année dans le
même cas kim anh des jeunes parfois
perdus ou en échec scolaire l'école de
la deuxième chance leur donne l'occasion
de prendre un nouveau départ et des
rentrées ont lieu tous les mois et le
parcours au sein de l'établissement se
fait de manière personnalisée ce qui
permet de trouver rapidement une
solution pour l'avenir de l'élève et
volkl bonnardel
du gène ça veut dire trouver un métier
sortir avec avec une formation avec un
travail en tout cas sortir avec un truc
qui est positif à l'école de la deuxième
chance les jeunes alternent entre deux
semaines de cours et deux semaines de
stage dans le milieu professionnel
il bénéficie d'une rémunération
mensuelle et de la gratuité dans les
transports franciliens au sein de
l'établissement les élèves sont épaulés
sur les savoirs fondamentaux français
maths ou encore bureautique et sont
accompagnés individuellement par un
formateur référent qui les soutient dans
toutes leurs démarches
une petit bonheur c'est de voir
justement que tout d'un coup ils sont
capables de trouver par eux mêmes
devoirs que tout d'un coup ils sont
capables de comprendre qu'effectivement
non ils sont pas plus nul que les autres
au contraire quoi c'est juste le système
qui peut être les a écrasés d'une façon
ou d'une autre je n'en sais rien mais en
tout cas j'aime bien les voir grandir et
se rendre compte de ce qu'il de leur
valeur l'établissement est présent sur
trois sites dans le département attrape
les mureaux et magnanville chaque année
plus de 400 jeunes passent par les rangs
de l'école de la deuxième chance des
yvelines
l'actualité de cette semaine c'est aussi
l'ouragan rma qui touche les antilles
jeudi à 13 son pied yvelinois ont pris
la direction des différentes îles
touchées par l'ouragan de classe 5 et
d'une violence jamais enregistrée parmi
les effectifs on compte notamment un
chien et son maître afin d'aider dans la
recherche des survivants sur place des
renforts supplémentaires pourraient être
également renvoyé envoyée
dans les prochains jours les pompiers
toujours dans l'actualité mais à plaisir
est dans une toute autre actualité
beaucoup plus positive celle ci la ville
de plaisir organise tous les étés des
stages est découverte pour les 8 13 ans
mardi soir se tenait la cérémonie de
remise des médailles
reportage et diplômes à la main sourire
aux lèvres devant leurs camarades de
promotion et leurs parents près d'une
cinquantaine d'enfants de plaisir et ses
environs se voient récompensés de leurs
efforts ils ont participé durant l'été à
un stage de trois jours avec les
sapeurs-pompiers plaisir wa un stage en
forme de rêve pour beaucoup d'entre eux
et pour se mettre dans la peau d'un
professionnel fait la grande échelle
on a fait
on a fait une fois mon affaire le
bataille d'eau et c'était c'était bien
mais ce que monsieur salle et nous a
arrosé voilà on a pris les numéros
d'appel d'urgence
on est monté à une grande échelle à 30
mètres on a fait du rappel on est allé
dans un bar où c'est une sorte de derby
râble dans le noir mis en place par la
mairie de plaisir depuis 15 ans en
partenariat avec le centre secours local
ces stages estivaux ont surtout une
portée pédagogique respect efforts
physiques notamment permet de mieux
répercuter certains enseignements
le premier objectif c'est de faire un
lien entre la population de plaisir et
des environs avec le métier de sapeur
pompier pour que la population comprenne
dès le plus jeune âge une omission
après un autre objectif c'est de leur
apprendre nous dans notre rôle de
prévention
c'est de leur apprendre leur faire
passer des messages de prévention sur le
numéro de téléphone d'urgence sur les
premiers gestes à réaliser lors d'une
intervention d'urgence de nouvelles
sessions sont prévues l'été prochain les
inscriptions débuteront en juin et d'ici
là les jeunes stagiaires pourront
diffuser leurs connaissances à l'école
jeudi l'agglomération de saint quentin
en yvelines organisé son premier salon
du tourisme d'affaires à la ferme du
manier de montigny le bretonneux
le sky maïs des a réuni le temps d'une
après-midi professionnels du marché et
entreprises à la recherche d'événements
particuliers les détails avec ce
reportage
que ce soit une scène de crime des
animaux ou encore une sarbacane géante
voilà des situations et des loisirs
difficile à imaginer entre collègues
et pourtant c'est bien l'objectif de ce
premier salon du tourisme d'affaires
proposer aux entreprises des solutions
innovantes lorsqu'elles cherchent à
renforcer la cohésion de leur équipe et
on est vraiment sur un objectif de
travailler ensemble de la cohésion
fédérer les équipes on est vraiment sur
cette surface qui colle à la travailler
ensemble dans un but commun que ce soit
sortir d'une pièce en 90 minutes ou
alors résoudre l'énigme le meurtre qui a
été commis on essaye de trouver des
idées un petit peu plus sympathique un
simple dîner
autour d'un événement particulier donc
d'où l'idée d'animations particulières
voilà les scènes de crime là derrière je
pense que ça peut être très sympa près
d'une cinquantaine de prestataires
étaient présents à la ferme du manet
pour répondre à une demande en pleine
croissance le tourisme d'affaires c'est
un marché de plus de 4 milliards d'euros
en ile de france avec ses seize mille
sociétés ses nombreuses installations
sportives et culturelles l'agglomération
de saint quentin en yvelines souhaite
profiter de cette dynamique en parlant
en échangeant sur différentes sur
différents rendez vous on s'est rendu
compte que d'une part il y avait une
véritable offre que les partenaires ne
se connaissaient pas forcément donc
c'était bien de les réunir et ensuite
que les entreprises de saint quentin en
yvelines était sans doute demandeuses
d'événements mais qu'elle n'en avait pas
connaissance et le marché semble promis
à un bel avenir pour les entreprises
spécialisées du territoire la ryder cup
en 2018 est très certainement les jeux
olympiques en 2024 seront à coup sûr des
porteurs d'affaires à leur mesure plus
d'écho pour la scène locale c'est le
nouvel axe de la politique culturelle du
café de la plage à maurepas la salle
yvelinoise reconstruite
tout juste il ya cinq ans ne
n'accueillera plus désormais de tête
d'affiche mais fera la promotion
exclusive des artistes locaux
raison avancée par la municipalité une
baisse de la fréquentation du lieu
le point avec mélanie poquet un café de
la plage redéfinit est consacrée aux
groupes locaux
pour cette saison la ville de mort pas à
changer sa politique culturelle
une des raisons un manque d'attrait du
public probablement une saison pas très
attirante peu de place au café de la
plage donc beaucoup de groupes ne sont
pas intéressés par ces petites
ces petites zones d'eau et puis nous ça
nous coûte très très cher
les coûts sont très importants les
entrées ont beaucoup diminué
finalement assez peu de maurepas siens
au café de la plage donc il fallait qu
on réoriente notre politique ce qui
était compliqué si vous voulez c'est que
on avait un budget programmation environ
20000 euros en 2016 35000 euros en
2010 est donc une augmentation de 15
mille euros pour le café de la plage
grâce au fonds de concours de saint
quentin en yvelines
malgré sept
cette augmentation de
de dotations sur la programmation on n'a
pas vu des faits se faire sentir sur le
public
le café accueillera aussi des
expositions les têtes d'affiché elles
seront reçues à l'espace albert camus
d'une plus grande capacité d'accueil une
décision découverte pendant l'été par
l'opposition certains élus y voit une
structure vidé de sa substance
d'autres comme michel chappe à un
désintérêt pour la jeunesse je n'ai pas
connaissance qui ait eu un travail de
commission pour réfléchir à ces
questions là comme d'habitude sous
couvert de mutualisation sous couvert
dans réorientation de fait l'activité du
café de la plage est terminée une
fermeture démentie par la majorité
municipale la saison culturelle de mort
par reprend le 23 septembre
du sport à présent et les cougars qui
fouleront bientôt leur nouveau terrain
l'équipe de baseball de montigny le
bretonneux va bénéficier d'un stade
rénové pour la prochaine saison les
travaux ont débuté en juillet et
concerne notamment la pose d'un
revêtement synthétique dernière
génération
le point avec notre journaliste sportif
michael et demi d'euros le stade jean
marc et celle de montigny le bretonneux
et en plein lifting la ville a déboursé
près de six cent quarante deux mille
euros pour rénover les terrains de la
structure pendant l'intersaison le
synthétique daté du début des années
2000 on va voir quand même 1 400 éthique
de qualité conforme à l'usagé baseball
chose qui n'était pas forcément évident
sur l'ancienne moquette
bon après on a aussi les normes qui
évolue régulièrement donc là on sera
vraiment à jour des dernières normes
commencent à être usées
les joueurs partent et avec une grande
partie du terrain dans leurs chaussettes
tous les soirs après les matches après
les entraînements
et puis surtout il était devenu très dur
et ça commençait à leur donner mal au
genou après avoir débuté en juillet les
travaux qui devaient s'achever en août
ont pris du retard
la livraison définitive est finalement
programmée d'ici fin septembre
des délais qui ont poussé le club des
cougars de monti le bretonneux à jouer
leur quart de finale des play-off de d1
contre paris à l'extérieur il vaut mieux
attendre et puis avoir quelque chose qui
correspondent tout à fait à nos attentes
et je pense que
vu ce que l'on nous a dit que nous
allions avoir ça va correspondre
forcément une fois terminée la structure
accueillera entre 180 et 200 joueurs par
semaine et des groupes scolaires
on referme cette émission avec un rendez
vous traditionnel du début du mois de
septembre les fameuses les fameux forum
associatif vous le voyez ils sont
organisés tout ce week-end sur saint
quentin en yvelines et principalement le
samedi comme à coignières de 9h30 à
17h30 au gymnase du moulin vert à magny
les hameaux hausse est de 9 heures 30 ce
samedi à 16 heures au gymnase
chantal mauduit un seul forum sera
organisé dimanche c'est aux
clayes-sous-bois de 10h à 18h à l'espace
philippe noiret toutes les informations
sont à retrouver sur notre site internet
ou sur le site internet de
l'agglomération sky point fr c'est la
fin de ce set 8 hebdo mais retour de
l'information en direct lundi à partir
de 18h sur tv 78 d'ici là restez
informés et connecté grâce à nos réseaux
sociaux tv soixante dix huit bon
week-end à tous et à la semaine
prochaine
[Musique]
m